I want to compliment you you so many
celebrities they live in one of two
places I live in LA or they live in New
York City okay and then they they think
of the rest is the flyover States in
this condescending way you're a real guy
you live in Chelsea Michigan is that
correct that is correct good for you
yeah
now what but what made you go to Chelsea
Michigan do you have roots there and
what made you stay well Mike Kathleen my
wife is from there I'm from there after
ten years of New York we said why don't
we just go home and live there because
the career is gonna end it will be over
soon you were very pessimistic about
I've got I don't know I got terms of
endearment a couple I'm going that's
probably it
so let's just go home so that when we
get the call that I'm over I'll be home
here's the one I'm serious that's the
weird thing Jeff there's no call that
it's over no but there is there's just
just the phone doesn't ring there's no
one person who calls and says it's over
yeah see that's what and you live in
Michigan that's what you think
yeah we don't no no no I have had the
same thought I have the first time I
made any money I bought a really like a
little house in in Connecticut on top of
a hill and I just have kept held on to
it because I keep thinking when it's
over I'm just gonna go there and rake
leaves and like some young kids gonna
cut something go like in comedy didn't
you used to be income I go down to the
local store and I stand there and I feel
like that old guy who goes down to the
store yeah because he's got nothing else
to do yeah day ya know you got in cities
they call them perverts
[Laughter]
you